should accept yourself just the way you
are what does that say about who I
should become is that just now off the
table because I'm already good enough in
every way so am I done or something get
the hell up get your act together adopt
some responsibility put your life
together develop a vision unfold all
those manifold possibilities that lurk
within be a force for good in the world
and that'll be the adventure of your
life
[Music]
it's hard for people to understand what
ESG means and if you first hear about it
you know it sounds kind of good because
you think well those damn greedy
corporations should be
incentivized to serve more than their
narrow self-interest but then
when you start to look at exactly what
that means like the devil's always in
the details you see very clearly that
this is just another variant of of
deeply socialist centralized State
planning these policies are actually
making everything worse by the criteria
of the people who put the policies in
place and that's just absolutely
unacceptable what we're doing is we're
saying look um you know some of our
states the signature industry is oil
coal or gas
um and and we're saying look where
Market participants too
we don't have to use your bank or your
fund manager to manage our billions of
dollars in business if we don't if we
think that you're actually trying to
hurt the primary industry of our state
[Music]
hello everyone so I'm talking today with
Derek kreifultz who is CEO of the State
financial officers Foundation
and normally perhaps under normal
conditions that might not be an
um something notable for all concern but
in the crazy upside down clone world
that we all currently inhabit this has
become incredibly relevant so I met
Derek a couple of days ago although I've
been retweeting a lot of what he's been
putting out on Twitter for quite a while
and uh I wanted to talk to him today so
that everybody watching and listening
can be brought up to date about what's
going on on the financial front in
relationship to states and their
investment strategies so Derek let's
start with a little bit about your
background and about your situation your
position right now and then we'll we'll
talk in some detail about exactly what
it is that you're doing with the other
State financial officers so
um who are you
uh well uh thank you for the opportunity
to be here first of all
um it's an honor to to get to talk to
you and um had an opportunity to see
your your show and uh just uh inspiring
to see the Young Generation respond to
truth and courage the way that you've
demonstrated it so thank you
um I uh I'm just a guy from Kansas from
a small town in Kansas I served as the
deputy treasurer of Kansas for six years
uh during that time
I worked with a group of State
treasurers and we realized that there
was a a need for an opportunity to come
together to talk about some of the State
uh Financial issues Public Finance
issues both at the federal and state
level from an unapologetically free
market perspective
um and and so there were other Treasures
organizations operating but none of them
really were excited to talk about it
from that free market perspective like
we were so myself and eight other state
treasurers co-founded the State
financial officers Foundation uh 11
years ago
and together we've just been raising
awareness and and educating the public
and these uh officials as they get
elected
um on issues of Public Finance whether
it's dealing with five to nine College
savings plans that a lot of the
treasures administer
um unclaimed property that they
administer
um some of them sit on Boards of State
pensions some manage enormous State
banking contracts some manage short-term
treasuries and so
uh we have a saying in our in our world
that if you've seen one state
treasurer's office you've seen one state
treasurer's office because they're all a
little bit different based on state
statutes and so I have this uh honor to
work with all of them across the country
and kind of bring them together and help
connect the ones that might have another
idea that might work in another state
and I try to connect them and be the
glue relationally how many state
treasurers are now part of this State
financial officers Foundation
great question so uh we started with
eight now today we're at 35 State
financial officers and we say Financial
officers Jordan because we have state
treasurer state auditor State
Controllers uh everybody's got a little
bit different title so like in Florida
it's CFO Jimmy Patronus in in Texas it's
a comptroller Glenn Hager so um we have
a total of 35 officials from 28 States
28 States how many of those are
Republican
all of them okay so it's a rep it's
fundamentally a republican organization
and is is that purposeful or is it the
fact that because it's free market
oriented the Democrats are less likely
to involve themselves do they have their
own equivalent on the Democrat side
yeah they they there is a group called
The Democratic Treasures Association we
are not blatantly Republican though
we've had an independent uh a treasure
uh be a part of our group I think when
you when in the beginning when we would
invite other Democratic treasures and
you you know use the phrase free market
it just tended to attract a certain kind
of elected official
um and so uh you know we have uh opened
our doors and invited multiple you know
folks from different parties in uh but
of course um the ones that are really
interested in and keying on that free
market uh perspective are usually
Republicans right right so do you want
to tell everybody
broadly speaking what a state treasurer
and the other uh individuals who are
involved in your organization what
they're primarily responsible for and
also how that relates to the elected
officials and then also why that's
relevant for citizens who are listening
because people need to know well why
they should care about what state
treasurers do like what impact is it
going to have on their on their
day-to-day lives
absolutely the easiest way to think
about a state treasurer or or one of
these Financial officers is that they
really are the Chief Financial Officer
for their state
um they they see the inflows and the
outflows they see the revenues coming in
from you know tax revenues or other or
other sources and they see that the way
that the state spends the money most of
them manage the state's checkbook right
so they really see the day-to-day
transactions
um one thing that we did when we first
started sfof
was we did a poll and we asked in
several States who do you trust more on
State financial matters we gave them the
choice of their governor their state
treasurer or their member of Congress
and the lowest that a state treasurer
received was 60 percent
um the governor the governor was usually
20 to 25 percent and the member of
Congress regardless of party was trusted
less than 10 percent of the time in on
in issues of of Public Finance and so we
knew that we had a really powerful uh uh
um tool to leverage where
um you know a lot of people don't think
about those these down ballot offices
very much you know that's not as as sex
as sexy as being Governor or U.S senator
or uh but but these men and women are on
the front lines watching the dollars and
cents and frankly watching how uh
decisions that are made in Washington
impact uh you know the lives on the
ground in the state from a financial
perspective so why do you think that the
gov that the treasurers were more
trusted
um you know I think it's just simply
because they don't get involved in a lot
of other issues
um you know if you take into account you
know a governor or member of Congress
well at first I'd say that when it comes
to a member of Congress you know there's
very few people that I think would say
that they can trust the United States
Congress on in terms of financial
restraint or or financial responsibility
um I think for Governors they're just
such they're involved in such a breadth
of issues that you know if if you it's
it's much easier to make friends or foes
depending on where you land on whether
they're social issues or financial
issues
um and I think you know just the simple
fact that most of the state treasurer
State Auditors really are focused on
fiduciary duty fiduciary responsibility
um I think I think that's why the
general public tends to gravitate
towards those officials when it comes to
things regarding money in their state
how would you define because there's
going to be a crucial issue in our
discussion as we go forward how would
you define fiduciary responsibility
I'd say fiduciary responsibility is
um when someone is in a position of
authority responsible for uh some pool
of money or or organization uh of money
that uh they are they are required by by
law many times
um at least in theory to do what's best
uh in the best interest of that
organization uh or in this example for a
state right and so that's there's also
something kind of local about that so
you know if you're if you're involved in
a corporation and you have a fiduciary
responsibility within the corporation
your responsibility to the shareholders
of the corporation and I would say the
consumers as well or the customers is to
do what you can ethically at the level
of that institution and so your proper
role is to serve the interests of the
shareholders how however that might be
constituted rather than the interests of
some third party or alternative
organization which would mean you're in
some sense operating as a fifth column
so if you do your fiduciary duty you're
undertaking the role that's being
assigned to you at the level that's been
assigned to you and that's going to be a
crucial issue as we as we progress with
this conversation because what's been
happening and this is partly why you've
become active on Twitter I would say in
other social media chapters is that the
fiduciary responsibility of states and
corporations alike has started to become
subordinated to other
interests let's say and that's
particularly true on the ESG front and
so maybe you could walk everybody who's
listening through that Rat's Nest we
could talk about what ESG means we just
need a definition for it and then also
why that the existence of these G
principles might constitute a conflict
with fiduciary duty
internet service providers operate like
monopolies in the regions they serve
what's worse many isps log your internet
activity so they can legally turn around
and sell that data to Big tech companies
or advertisers for a profit to prevent
isps from tracking your internet
activity protect all your devices with
expressvpn expressvpn is a simple app
that encrypts your network data and
tunnels it through a secure server their
trusted server technology makes it
impossible for expressvpn's own servers
to store any data they're so confident
and they're no logs claim they even had
one of the biggest Assurance firms PwC
audit their technology expressvpn is
incredibly easy to use as well you just
fire up the app and click one button it
works on all devices so you can stay
secure on the go and expressvpn doesn't
slow your connection that's why it's
rated number one by CNET wired and tech
radar visit expressvpn.com Jordan that's
expr essvpn.com Jordan and get three
extra months free Express vpn.com Jordan
[Music]
that's uh that's a lot to unpack um it's
a good thing we've got some time uh but
ESG stands for environmental social and
governance uh and it's it's frankly it's
a type of of investing
um where a group of activists have are
frankly uh weaponizing uh public Capital
Money uh to advance a a political agenda
um and it could be done in in the name
of numerous issues
um lately it's been focused on the
environmental climate change issues
um the S the social part of ESG tends to
cover some of the biggest social issues
of our of our time whether it's abortion
uh whether it's second amendment rights
it can even be connected to some of the
issues of anti-Semitism happening around
the country
um
and then governance uh is is uh the the
uh under that is just making sure that
you're you have good governance that
you're not maybe making
um racial quotas uh but you're getting
good fiduciary members you're getting
good board members
um that have the experience to be able
to turn that uh make those decisions for
the shareholder right the best way they
can so the people who've been putting
this forward are operating please
correct me at any time when I haven't
got this exhaustion all right so they're
putting forward a vision that the
corporate Enterprise
regardless of at what level it's
operating should be subordinated to a
set of hypothetically ethical principles
and that's often brought forward under
the guise of stakeholder capitalism is
that merely merely serving the
shareholders interests isn't sufficient
that corporations should be required or
at least encouraged but generally
required to take a much broader view of
the world and they should subordinate
their corporate concerns to well let's
walk through it environmental issues
well what does that mean well it in
principle what it means is that we
accept that the corporations are
required to accept the story that the
um world on the environmental front is
hovering on the brink of disaster
positive feedback or Tipping Point
induced disaster that that's uni the
cause of that is unidimensional and the
cause essentially is overproduction of
carbon dioxide and that that that's such
a pressing problem that all other issues
should be subordinated to its uh
diminishment as rapidly as possible so
that's and then there's other
environmental concerns that might come
out of that but the fundamental issue
here is that all corporate
Enterprises and activities should be
subordinated to this radical
environmentalist Viewpoint and then on
the social front what you have
brought into the fold is essentially the
diversity equity and inclusivity
movement in all of its tentacular spent
Splendor and there's an association with
a particularly quite radical left-wing
view of the world that gets brought into
the corporate domain on that front
insisting that people should be
identified primarily by their race or
their sex or their gender or their
sexual preference and that that
identification constitutes grounds for
the distribution of resources and
position and then well what's happening
with ESG on the governance front is
somewhat more unclear I would say as
opposed to environment social but the
fundamental proposition here is that
merely serving the interests of the
corporation and the shareholders is
insufficient that has to be subordinated
to a broader View and you know there's
something kind of compelling about that
because we know that local mere greed on
the part of corporate entities can cause
a substantial amount of problems but the
the emergent problem seems to be that
subordinating that fiduciary duty to
something like Central planning oriented
along a radical left environmental
apocalyptic scheme is not going to
redress those problems and by any
measure that I know of is likely to make
them worse and this has become
particularly crucial in recent years for
everyone watching and listening because
there are major
hedge funds in particular
BlackRock and Vanguard foremost among
them who have and they control as a
staggering amount of investment money I
can and almost incomprehensible amount
of investment money they've joined the
ESG Club so to speak and our punishing
corporations and States who don't abide
by ESG mandates is that now if I got any
of that wrong
yeah um well I was just there's a few
things I would just clarify
um I think that you know you're right
that these giant fund managers you know
BlackRock uh was worth about eight
trillion dollars as of the first of this
year I think State Street is the other
one that's really big it's three to four
trillion dollars
um they're really leveraging uh the the
money that they manage on behalf of
these State pensions which is you know
everyday Americans money and they're
then leveraging them to advance these
social causes and our issue isn't
necessarily the fact that someone would
choose to invest this way to invest
their personal dollars
um if they wanted to invest in a fund
that protects the environment or that
does you know something on a social
issue that's their choice and that's the
great thing about America
um and but what we have a real problem
with is when the billions of dollars
that are being invested by BlackRock by
State Street
um by some of these other companies uh I
I Vanguard has been one of those players
but they've they've recently just made
some public comments their CEO Tim
Buckley was just making some comment
about uh that ESG is not a a winning
proposition from a financial perspective
um let's point out very clearly which
means that it is not a winning
proposition right it's like there's no
it's a winning proposition except on the
financial front it's like no no no
that's the measure and so and so yeah so
your argument is people can invest in
whatever the hell they want and
absolutely fair enough you know if you
want to invest in a corporation or buy
the products of a corporation that
purports to be serving the environment
that's all well and good but when it
starts to become mandatory and failure
to do so
results in punitive consequences that's
a whole different ball of wax and of
course that's exactly the problem that
you guys are dealing with at the State
Treasury level and the reason for that
just so everyone's clear is that you you
part of your fiduciary duty is to ensure
that such things as people's pensions
programs are properly uh funded and
invested from an investment perspective
because your job is to make bloody well
sure that the money in the Pension funds
for example is stable and hopefully also
growing and if there are any outside
influences that are going to interfere
with that then you're it's appropriate
for you to be uh what would you say to
oppose that in every manner that you
possibly can and so that's sort of where
we're at at the moment as far as I can
tell and and so what are the what does
what's your organization's concern about
and stance with regards to ESG investing
and what have you done about it
yeah so we um we have made a very public
stance our members our state Treasures
our public officials
um you know are really working in each
of their states to do what they think is
best for their state
um you know and they back up and just
say that there is this movement
internationally uh that came out of the
Glasgow Accords that's climate action
for Net Zero there's a group called The
Global Financial Alliance for Net Zero
which are basically all of the big Banks
and fund managers that are are making
commitments on their websites they're
saying you know that they're going to be
Net Zero by 2030 or 2040 they're all
making a little bit different
commitments but um you know what we're
doing is we're saying look um you know
some of our states the signature
industry is oil coal or gas
um and and we're saying look where
Market participants too
we don't have to use your bank or your
fund manager to manage our billions of
dollars in business if we don't if we
think that you're actually trying to
hurt the primary industry of our state
so take example a state treasure Riley
Moore in West Virginia who one year ago
was able to work with his legislature to
pass legislation to basically say look
if you are a State Bank working with any
level of state government University
Systems Etc that was one of the
authorities that he had was he could say
we're not going to work with you anymore
if you're if you're we're choosing to uh
you know not work with coal for example
um it's one thing if it's if it's not a
good business decision maybe the company
is having some issues and you know there
it's just not a good business model you
get the business plan it's not good you
know Bankers can do that that's their
right but to say flat out we're just not
going to do business with anybody that
touches coal
um we had a problem with that and
treasure Moore had a really big problem
with that
um and so the law passed uh he put six
banks on notice including BlackRock
um Citibank JP Morgan Chase uh I think
Goldman Sachs was in there U.S Bank
ended up changing their position uh to
say okay we're going to back off of our
prohibition of coal we'll we'll do
business with the coal industry and they
were allowed to stay in the mix of State
contractors who managed the state's
money
um and so we've seen other solutions
that have popped up again there's not
like a one-size-fits all we're not
pushing out some you know
um we're not pushing out some you know
one-size solution for every state each
one's a little different Kentucky passed
a similar law but theirs is more on All
State contractors who work with the
state to a certain Financial level if
they are actively discriminating against
and that's what it is really we're
talking about energy discrimination
these these core these corporations
choose using to discriminate against the
fossil fuel industry in this in this you
know mad rush to go to Net Zero
um you know a lot of people talk about
that mad rush too because yeah people
people listening might think well you
know wouldn't it be good if we could
move away from coal and you know I think
you can make an argument on that front
in some ways if you're very careful that
the careful replacement for example of
coal with liquid natural gas might be a
net good all things considered in some
situations and then the possible
replacement of liquid natural gas even
with nuclear but you have to be willing
to allow liquid natural gas and you need
to be willing to allow and encourage
nuclear and you also have to understand
that liquid natural gas is also
necessary for the production of ammonia
for example which only feeds 4 billion
people and so this notion and everyone
watching and listening should be super
clear about this this notion that Net
Zero on the carbon in front is necessary
is a Lie the idea that we're going to
manage it by 2030 is preposterous Beyond
Comprehension I mean the Biden
Administration itself has already
admitted that it will be 240 years with
with optimistic projections before we
can approximate anything like Net Zero
so all this is just a complete bloody
lie and he might say well you know it's
no worse a lie than many other lies than
we've been told and I suppose that might
be true except that what we're seeing in
places like Germany for example is that
as we move hypothetically towards these
idiot pathological Net Zero sloganeering
propositions we get more unreliable
power at a much higher cost like four to
five times as high so that industry
starts to move to places like China
which by the way don't have the best
environmental regulations and it's made
Germany hyper reliant on Russia and more
to the point even on the environmental
front is there's no evidence whatsoever
that what Germany has done well they've
devastated their reliable sources of
power has improved the environment one
bit in fact quite the contrary the world
used more coal last year than it ever
has in the entire history of the planet
and that's partly because partly because
countries like Germany have been re
forced to rely on coal as a backup for
their idiot renewable projects because
they're too unreliable and they've shut
down their nuclear plants so anybody
who's listening who thinks well you know
maybe the environmentalists are going
too far but coal should be off the table
it's like you simply don't know what the
hell you're talking about it's also the
case that for many people around the
world especially in developing nations
coal
is a hell of a lot better and a lot less
polluting than wood and the the option
isn't coal or nothing or coal or liquid
natural gas or nuclear in many
developing countries the option is coal
or or would or done which is you know
one of your the world's lower quality uh
sources of energy let's say hey Reagan I
know you're picky when it comes to skin
care products so tell me what did you
think of genucel skin care that's
exactly right Garrett I'm the type of
person who wants to know exactly what
ingredients I'm using in my skincare
routine which is why I'm loving genucel
their products are made with
antioxidants and formulated by a
compounding pharmacist and they're all
about preventative skin care with Summer
coming up around the corner I'll be
using genucel's powerful retinol
alternative which is safe to use on your
skin in the hot summer sun they also
have a dark spot corrector which helps
reduce the appearance of dark marks and
sunspots right now you can get them both
in genucel's most popular package at
genucel.com Jordan you heard it here
first don't miss out on this amazing
deal just in time for warmer days ahead
go to genucel.com Jordan to get 70 off
their most popular package every Aura
subscription includes a luxury gift box
with two free Springtime Essentials
that's two free gifts plus free shipping
go to genucel.com Jordan genucel.com
Jordan
so one of the reason I'm on this rant is
because I want to make sure that
everybody who's listening knows
perfectly well that even by the
standards of the environmentalists
themselves these this ESG movement
especially combined with Net Zero is not
only not going to work it's not going to
work there's not a chance it'll work it
will absolutely make things worse on the
environmental front as well as dipping
propelling a lot of people into poverty
undermining the stability that we take
for granted on the industrial front make
power more unreliable and also tilt the
world towards dependence on well
dictatorial sources of power like an
energy like or obtained in in Russia at
the moment
well and I'm really glad you bring up
the the issue of poverty because uh
American energy energy around the world
has has done more for human flourishing
than any other any other sector right
you take away that country including
coal if you take away a country's
ability to produce coal natural gas oil
uh you know you can a great case study
would be to look at the country of Sri
Lanka and what developed last summer
right where they didn't even have gas to
cook on little stoves in their homes
because of the federal regulations that
had been implemented that were pushed
down on the people they couldn't pay for
gas for their their cars it's an island
nation and it was an absolute disaster
so we know that this is uh you know and
how that translates here there was
actually
um a video that came out just I think
today on Fox News uh with the National
homebuilders Association talking about a
a a proposition that's being voted on in
the Bay area of California where they're
trying to basically say no more gas
stoves no more gas hot water heaters no
more gas you know anything
um and and the home builders
associations are basically saying look
that's going to drive prices so high
that the homeless problem is going to
increase
um and so uh so it's a really big uh
misnomer to think that we can get to
this net Z this fantasy world of Net
Zero
um and then still have uh you know human
flourishing and and modern the modern
Technologies there's a great
organization that I have to give credit
to um life-powered uh part of the Texas
public policy Foundation has this great
video
that shows from you know the time that
you wake up in the morning until you get
to your office just in that first one
and a half hours of your day how many uh
petrochemical products are involved in
your life whether it's you're in your
alarm clock in your bed sheets in your
clock and your toothbrush and you know
all of those things
um and and so this this idea that we
would somehow uh you know this is I
think this is where the struggle really
is uh for these treasures and Auditors
is we have companies like BlackRock like
State Street who are actively saying and
actively encouraging the companies that
they invest in uh that they want this
this you know this Net Zero by a certain
date
and they want that for America
but what they're not telling the
American people is that they're taking
those dollars that they're investing on
behalf of all these pensioners in
America
and they're trying to invest and
leverage them so they can do business in
China it's a huge new retail audience
China is the largest polluter on the
Earth
they have five times the number of
coal-fired power plants
then America does we had about 225 in
2021 they have about uh
1118 I believe well I think I found that
China is planning to build more coal
plants than there are coal plants in the
world yeah and the other thing they're
building one about every two weeks right
we don't want it they're building guys
China precisely too because had we not
been so utterly clueless on the energy
front in the West
we would have been able to supply the
Chinese with a much more reliable supply
of liquid natural gas so that's a
particularly egregious sin on the
Canadian front because our idiot prime
minister Trudeau has done everything he
possibly could to shut down the Canadian
fossil fuel industry and all that means
is that well as you already pointed out
that China has found it necessary so its
people don't starve to produce more and
more coal plants which is exactly also
what's happening in India and we could
have remediated that to a large degree
if we hadn't been damned foolish for the
last 60 years especially on the nuclear
front but also in relationship to liquid
natural gas and so and then for all of
you who still might be residual
environmentalists listening you better
bloody well understand that if we don't
build a coal plant in North America or
Australia but we build one in China it's
the same damn air and so the fact that
we're making it impossible for any of
these things to occur in the west just
means it's offloaded into another
country and that might be fine if it was
only a matter of pollution of rivers
because then the Chinese could deal with
that and you know that's a peripheral
problem for us even though it's not
trivial but since they're dumping carbon
dioxide into the same damn atmosphere
that all this ethical posturing is doing
nothing it's not just not doing good
that's the thing we've got to get clear
here these policies are actually making
everything worse by the criteria of the
people who put the policies in place and
that's just absolutely unacceptable and
it's hard for people it's hard for
people to understand what ESG means and
if you first hear about it you know it
sounds kind of good because you think
well those damn greedy corporations
should be
incentivized to serve more than their
narrow self-interest but then
when you start to look at exactly what
that means like the devil's always in
the details you see very clearly that
this is just another variant of of
deeply socialist centralized State
planning and here's a question for you
you know you would expect that someone
like Larry Fink for example who's CEO of
BlackRock would be enough of an evil
capitalist not to saw off the branch
that he sits on it's like what the hell
is going on with these corporations who
are bending over backwards to adopt
these idiot ideological woke policies
when they're clearly enabling like fifth
Columns of ideologues who are
antithetical to absolutely everything
they stand for like what how do you
understand this or or do you guys even
bother trying to sort that sort of thing
out
well you know I would say I I would
guess that Larry Fink would probably say
it is capitalism that's driving him to
do more business in China
right it's a it's this huge audience of
untapped retail investors
and and the real again the height of
hypocrisy on this issue if we take the
social issues you know the left is
always talking about how important it is
to bring up the little guy and and the
left out and the the Forgotten but but
they're not talking about you know the
uyghur the Muslim uighurs in in China
they're not talking about the the
African children in the in the People's
Republic of the Congo that are having to
mine Cobalt for China uh you know in
order to produce all of the the electric
vehicles all of the lithium batteries
for our iPads phones there's a great new
book out I I don't profit At All by
promoting it I'm reading it right now
called Cobalt red uh Siddharth Kara I
think is the author who who went there
and saw these atrocities of these
um these you know African children who
are making maybe you know a dollar or
two a day to Cobalt this you know to
mine this dangerous mineral that China
you know now operates and controls about
60 of the world's Cobalt Supply
um China has been much smarter about
owning and buying Rich minerals than the
United States has and it's putting us at
a huge disadvantage and that's that's
the other thing that I think a lot of
our men and women are concerned about is
just the position that ESG investing
puts us in compared to countries like
China right well I don't have as much of
a problem with BlackRock dealing with
the Chinese because I think the issue of
how to include the Chinese in a broad
free market economy is one that still
requires a tremendous amount of debate
you know everybody hoped that China
would sort of sort itself out on the
Democratic front at least
quasi-democratic front as their
population became wealthier and less
prone to starvation and I think to a
limited degree that's occurred although
the Chinese have backslid terribly with
with the pronouncement of XI as like
ruler till the end of time and there
they're slide back into a real communist
totalitarianism I mean so it's not
exactly as if I'm a China fan especially
not one of the Chinese Communist party
but you know I can see BlackRock
investigating investment decisions I'm
more concerned curious about why in the
world they bought the entire
environmental apocalypse narrative along
with the Dei nonsense on the on the
governance or on the social front like
what is it about these capitalist
Enterprises that is tilting them in this
woke policy Direction why and how can
they not see how counterproductive that
is given that they're fundamentally
capitalist Enterprises I don't
understand that
I I don't either other than they believe
it right I mean that's what we have to
that's the that's the conclusion you
have to come to is they absolutely
believe that it's the right way to go I
think the other thing that I would say
is the conservative movement in America
um has been slow to respond to a lot of
this
um as they they have on other issues but
uh you know we I talked to to CEOs and
c-suite Executives on a regular basis
who frankly privately will tell me thank
you thank you for giving us leverage now
to say we're hearing now from both sides
so we're going to stay neutral on this
issue
um which at the end of the day that's
what these men and women want that's
what these State treasures and Auditors
want is they want Banks to be Banks
right doing more damn managers to be
fund managers that's right their
fiduciary duty calls for them to only
work with those companies that are
willing to to maintain and protect that
idea of fiduciary responsibility and sea
level c-level uh
Seashore levels are not part of that
fiduciary responsibility that's the
argument that the left is trying to make
is that that is fiduciary responsibility
and that's what the admire that's what
this Biden Administration is trying to
push out you know through the Department
of Labor through rule changes through
the Securities and Exchange Commission
uh requiring ESG disclosures they're
trying to say that it is fiduciary
responsible of you to pay attention and
know how that would be fine they were
investing their own money
that's right right because maybe you
know if you could make a case that
um keeping a corporate eye cast on the
20-year Horizon 30-year Horizon on the
environment front is going to guide your
investment decisions in a manner that
increases your profitability no problem
man if people want to bet on that that's
just fine but when it starts to become a
matter of compulsion and regulation then
nope you've definitely gone too far I
think people like Larry think for
example and all the corporate types who
are uh pursuing this ESG nonsense out of
guilt for example here's what I think is
going on it isn't the problem isn't that
they're capitalists
um the problem is is that they're evil
capitalists and what I mean by that is
that they're pursuing their ill-gotten
gains in an unethical manner
fundamentally and you know the left
criticizes gigantic corporate structures
for having this happen all the time and
it happens all the time so it's
certainly the case for example that big
Pharma falls into that category and you
can tell that because the biggest
lawsuits in the history of the world
have been successfully brought against
big Pharma and so there's no shortage of
evil on the capitalist front but to
attribute that to capitalism is foolish
now I think what happens with the CEO
types who go along with ESG and and Di
movements is they're guilty because of
their ill-gotten gains and which I am
not attributing to capitalism by the way
and so then they look for an easy moral
out either that or they look for a moral
out that they think the population is
gullible enough to buy and so they've
Banner wave and flag wave about Net Zero
and about the fact that we're going to
adopt our corporate responsibility
ability on the environmental front and
they do that because it's easier than
actually atoning for their greedy sins
let's say or they do that because they
think it's a good way of pulling the
wool over the Public's eyes or some you
know appallingly malevolent combination
of both because otherwise I don't
understand it like you have to be Daft
if you're a CEO not to notice that the
Dei Squad diversity ex
equity and inclusivity and the ESG Squad
put forward an ideology that is
absolutely antithetical to the
principles upon which your company are
based so then you say well why the hell
would you do that and one excuse is
ignorance you just don't know better but
this unatone for Guilt is another good
explanation and the lefties like Russell
Brand and Joe Rogan to some degree have
been pretty good at pointing this out
said yeah well you guys have bent the
system in your favor for a long time and
now you're guilty about it and so you're
gonna you're gonna comply in this Daft
manner with these idiot the ideologies
to everyone's discredit including
yourself and that's not going to tone
for your sins and it's going to make
everything a hell of a lot worse yeah
and I would say too uh that a lot of the
the students graduating from
universities today unfortunately are you
know pretty left of center and so the
really loud ones go to work for these
big publicly traded companies and that's
how this whole idea of stakeholder
capitalism comes in is suddenly your
employee is a stakehold folder even if
they're not a shareholder that they have
some say and I think that that's part of
why they get caught up in these
decisions as well is they're listening
to this younger generation who may have
this you know idealistic thought of of
change or of and and it may be a really
small very loud minority it is
definitely that screaming that yeah well
I've seen that they're listening I've
seen that in my own dealings with
corporations so for example in Canada I
publish with penguin random house and
there was a bit of a rebellion among the
younger people at penguin Random House
when they decided to publish my my next
popular book right so I have a two
volume series now the first book which
was 12 rules for life was one of the
most profitable books that penguin
Random House in Canada ever published by
a huge margin and so I was responsible
for a substantial fraction of prhs
Revenue over the last six years and yet
when my second book was announced before
anyone had read it there was a rebellion
among the younger people and then
penguin Random House had a town hall
where a number of them cried about and I
mean literally cried about what a
terrible monster I was despite the fact
they hadn't read the damn book and
instead of firing all those people which
is exactly 100 percent what should have
instantly happened since they lined
themselves up to identify themselves as
people who should be fired because they
wanted to implement censorship on a book
they hadn't read in a publishing house
all that happened was that prh hand
waved about how upset their new people
were and tried to
um what would you say listen
compassionately to their concerns and
move forward and you know
um
they didn't end up canceling my book
which you know I don't regard precisely
as a favor but the same thing happened
also at prh in in New York
and so
but but again I see no excuse for it's
like why the hell would you go along
with the radicals you're you're so
uncertain about your own moral
principles even as a publisher that you
won't fire people within your
organization who are outright calling
for censorship
yeah stunning well and and I would just
add too one of the things that we've
realized over the year the last year and
a half as we've pushed back is uh you
know the three companies that we would
like to mention a lot the you know
BlackRock State Street Vanguard if you
look at the the ownership that they have
in the top 500 publicly traded companies
in America
they own anywhere from 18 to 20 on
average of of every one of those
publicly traded companies so they
leverage this tremendous amount of
authority
um we have you know in when we have
publicly traded companies we have this
whole thing that's getting ready to
start the you know the proxy the
shareholder voting season is this spring
right and that's what we've seen them do
is to start to direct behavior of
companies that they're going to invest
in if if buying BlackRock and I'm going
to invest in your company you're going
to make sure that you uh don't invest in
Coal that you don't invest in dirty
agriculture you don't invest in you know
and they've got this checklist
that all in the name of ESG uh and so
it's very correct it's coercion right
it's it's preventing farmers and small
businesses
um you know uh from a growing food note
that's right right I mean there's this
whole you know cattle methane mitigation
oh yeah right uh you know it's a big
part of of you know BlackRock had some
involvement with this data Nebraska for
example where they were you know there
was question about uh whether which
company they were going to invest in
because big cattle ranchers you know
cows poop and you know they produce
methane uh but uh you know that's part
of this movement is to kind of eliminate
that eliminate that industry yeah yeah
well that's pretty that feeds people yes
yes and and feeds poor people cheaply
okay so let's talk about exactly how
this came about because people aren't
going to understand this either okay so
now you just said BlackRock State Street
Vanguard owned between 15 and 25 of the
shares in the top 500 companies okay so
now how the hell did they manage to
accumulate all that Capital so why don't
we why don't you just walk through that
backstory so that people understand
what's happened over the last 20 years
with regards to these huge
um Corp I mean I think the very simple
answer is just that they've over time
they've accumulated uh you know huge
amounts of wealth and invested it back
in these publicly traded how did they
accumulate um so what are people doing
with their money that turns it over to
Blackrock
um
well they're investing in BlackRock
right right there walk us through what
black rock is and why that's put
position them so powerfully because
people aren't going to understand that
yeah so BlackRock uh manages everybody's
401K retirement fund it you know almost
every registered advisor uses BlackRock
uses eye shares
um and they are basically accumulating
all of this wealth from private
individuals who are you know unknowingly
investing you know money with their you
know retail advisor at their local you
know office on Main Street USA and then
they're taking those dollars and
investing them in ways that they want to
to drive this agenda so that's actually
why that's actually why we started our
educational campaign on December 1st we
started a campaign called our money our
values because what we realized was
there was this huge you know aside from
ESG being a little wonky and hard to
explain to the average American
um we needed to make sure that they
understood how it affected their bottom
line
um and yeah well so if you have a
retirement well so what's happening is
people have their their pension savings
and there's reason to invest that in the
stock market let's say to buy companies
now when you invest in a stock in the
stock market and you become a
shareholder you also have voting rights
now what's happened is that companies
like BlackRock as they've aggregated
individual investor Capital have accrued
the Voting Rights
to themselves
right and so and so they can they can
wield disproportionate influence
pretending to be the voice of the
individual investors but in reality
pushing forward this ESG agenda that
we've been describing often in a manner
that runs contrary to the fiduciary
interest of their investors and that
means all of you who are watching and
listening who have Pension funds and so
and that's put a tremendous amount of
power like an almost unlimited amount of
financial power in the hands of very few
actors and you laid out BlackRock
Vanguard and State Street and so that's
what we're talking about and people
people need to always know why this is
relevant to them it's relevant to them
because these are your this is your
pension money but not only that this is
your voting right
that is being
um secretly in some real sense and in an
underhanded manner if you're a
shareholder yep if you're a shareholder
yes
yeah and most people aren't voting
they're they're not voting their shares
they're not voting their proxy and Most
states weren't
um frankly they were depending on on
companies like ISS and glass Lewis who
are you know also owned a percentage
owned by BlackRock fan Garden State
Street to basically vote those shares of
for this on behalf of the state pensions
and that's been part of the rub and part
of the pushback from some of our States
now is you know either bringing just a
blatant transparency to how those Shares
are being voted what the issue is and
how the state pension uh you know
representative voted on those shares or
asking and and pushing to change
contracts with companies like BlackRock
so that they can't vote the state shares
anymore and that they have Personnel in
these State offices that can do that the
problem that we have are some state
treasurer's office you know employ
thousands and thousands of of state
employees
um you know 8 000 employees on in one
case and then you know there might be
eight employees in a smaller State and
so it's it's not a one-size-fits all
it's it's a big issue
we'll be right back first we wanted to
give you a sneak peek at Jordan's new
series Exodus
so the Hebrews created history as we
know it
you don't get away with anything and so
you might think you can bend the fabric
of reality and that you can treat people
instrumentally and that you can bow to
the Tyrant and violate your conscience
without cost you will pay the piper it's
going to call you out of that slavery
into Freedom even if that pulls you into
the desert
and we're going to see that there's
something else going on here that is far
more Cosmic and deeper than what you can
imagine the highest
[Music]
beholden is presented precisely as that
spirit that allies itself with the cause
of Freedom against tyranny I want
villains to get punished but do you want
the villains to learn before they have
to pay the ultimate price that's such a
Christian question
this probably would have worked
originally even if BlackRock would have
been voting on behalf of the investors
as long as what BlackRock was doing was
pursuing their local fiduciary interest
right because if your goal as a pension
investor is to make money and your and
your fund manager's goal is to make
money well then your interests are
aligned but if your goal is to make
money so that you're doing well for your
retirement and your manager's goal now
is to implement ESG requirements then
there's an instant conflict of interest
there and that's exactly what's emerged
especially in the last 10 years it's
hard to alert well to the danger of this
but it's a signal danger when I started
to become aware of esgs I thought well
I'm already preoccupied with diversity
inclusivity and Equity because that's an
absolute catastrophe especially on the
equity front it's devastated the
universities but I think ESG as if
anything worse it's like Dei on steroids
with much larger pools of capital and so
well they've they've learned that they
can weaponize money you know and and we
saw that first in your country you know
with the with the trucker protests
um that's where our men and women first
really kind of became aware that hey
here's a federal here's a federal
government that is literally shutting
down individual bank accounts so that
they can't fund protesters that they
don't agree with
I I mean it really it was absolutely
shocking to see that happen and then
we've seen that here now in the United
States where there are certain Banks who
are de-platforming debanking companies
if they don't like what you're selling
you know if they're if you're a if
you're a small uh gun owner gun shop
owner and there's there was a case of a
small gun shop owner in Florida that had
been in business for 20 some years
um and uh they got shut down by their
primary bank because they didn't want to
be in the gun business anymore
um not because of anything that owner
did not because they committed a crime
they didn't do any of that and this guy
was a veteran
um and so you know it's it's absolutely
ridiculous you know former U.S
ambassador for the religious freedom Sam
Brownback
um started an organization a
non-for-profit Organization for
Religious Freedom the organization was
was told that they couldn't have a bank
at the bank that they wanted to bank at
because uh they didn't like what they
were doing so
um so this idea of weaponizing capital
it's very dangerous and it is a it's
probably the largest issue that our
country is going to face over the next
couple years because now that we've seen
how one side can do it you know it's
going to be really easy for federal
bureaucracies for congress depending on
who's in control to start leveraging you
know public Capital to force a political
yeah well it's better on by the
development of anything approximating a
centralized digital currency so so yeah
you know Canadians have absolutely no
idea
what the Trudeau government lockdown of
bank accounts did to Canada is
international reputation or what sort of
precedent it served you know I regard
that as an act of outright treachery I
couldn't believe that our government
could do something that utterly
appalling and I also still can't believe
that about 50 percent of Canadians feel
that it was justified they have no idea
what that means they have no idea that
we now have a precedent in Canada such
that if you have a political opinion
that's unpopular no worse if you support
someone
indirectly who has a political opinion
that runs contrary to that of the
government that you can now lose access
to the entire Financial system you know
when people think well if you didn't do
anything wrong you wouldn't have
anything to worry about and the right
rejoiner to that is you've never done
anything wrong in your whole life eh
and you think that that the government
is so bloody uh virtuous that they're
only going to punish people who you know
are the real wrongdoers you're that
naive and Canadians have no idea what
like I said they have no idea whatsoever
how shocking it was across the world
that our government actually dared to
suspend the financial rights of of
people who were contributing to the
trucker the trucker Convoy with no trial
right by government Fiat top down
coercing the banks to do so one of the
banks actually apologized which was
quite the remarkable occurrence yeah
yeah I think it was the Bank of Nova
Scotia apologized for doing it but yeah
thanks guys you shouldn't have done it
to begin with but but yeah well that
that I think that action you know and
and that awareness to our men and women
that are in these offices
um you know became we became very
acutely aware and hypersensitive and so
we started reading uh there was a
proposal that the United States Treasury
Department put out it would it didn't
even have a chance to become an official
Bill in Congress but the idea was that
we're going to start monitoring every
American's bank accounts whether it's a
bank account Credit Union for 600
transactions inflow or outflow right so
if you take a deposit of 600 or more
boom that bank is required to report
that to the IRS if you get if you if you
write a check for a refrigerator that's
more than 60 or a gas stove
or a gas stove yes
um and so we a lot of our a lot of our
men and women really went to the front
line uh Nebraska treasure John moranti
really led the charge on that and said
look you know we cannot allow that to go
unnoticed you know we've got to raise
awareness so we we did a very strategic
move
um with the bankers the American Bankers
Association and the credit unions of of
America
um to get the word out to every blogger
every newspaper every radio show every
TV in in the states that we were in to
raise awareness and and really the
wonderful thing about that that
experience Jordan was that the average
American whether they were democrat or
republican they all hated the idea of
having the IRS monitoring every every
transaction in their bank account of 600
or more we got phone calls from people
that said I you know I don't want the
government or the IRS to know how much
medicinal marijuana I buy on a monthly
basis we we had Republicans calling you
calling and saying I don't want the
government to know how much ammunition I
buy on a regular basis
um and you know I don't want the
government what I buy period so I keep
your goal that's right now out of my
business you know and well the fact that
we're going to be able to track this
digitally is people have no idea what
that means it will mean that
decentralized controllers will start to
decide what it is that you need and what
you don't need and their answer will be
well because the planet is going to come
to an end in 20 years you really don't
need much at all you know the you know
you you read I suppose know a little bit
about these 15-minute cities and the the
right-wing conspiratorial trolls have
got all their panties into not about
15-minute cities and the lefties of
course uh declaim that that's nothing
but a conspiracy theory but if you go to
the C40 website and C40 is the website
that's put forward by the Consortium of
municipalities that are adopting the
15-minute City Vision they State very
very straightforwardly that their goals
are the radical minimization of Private
Car ownership by 2035. gas or electric
it doesn't matter because you goddamn
peasants don't need vehicles that people
should be limited to one flight every
three years on the vacation front
because you damn peasants really don't
need to go anywhere and that caloric
restriction is also on the carts so
first of all no meat for you that's for
sure but you're probably eating more
than you should anyways because after
all the planets at stake and so for
everyone who's listening and watching if
you think that having the government can
monitor everything that you purchase is
going to turn out well for you you
better bloody well wake up and if you
don't think that digital currency put
forward by the government is going to
facilitate that you're painfully you're
painfully asleep
so and what's going to be done about
that why like what do you guys think on
the digital currency front because it's
pretty damn obvious that essentially we
already have a digital currency that's
that's what a credit card is and at
least what's happening with our credit
card data is that mostly it's being used
by greedy corporations to sell us stuff
that we hypothetically want and there's
a fair bit of manipulation in that but
at least you know at least the ethos
there is to increase consumer
consumption and you might not think
that's the best possible use of data but
it's not the worst now
so the digital currency is already in
place and and the data that it generates
is basically controlled by corporate
interests if we put forward a digital
currency that's centralized the
fundamental recipient of the data is
going to be the government and God only
knows what they're going to do with that
data but this is definitely coming so
what do you what is your organization
what are you guys suggesting on the
digital currency front
well we're we don't have an answer yet
um that's an issue that we're tackling
later this year
um and have not spent a whole lot of
time on so I can't really speak to it I
can tell you that that you know we are
watching uh there is a I forget the name
of it there's a European uh agency that
that makes recommendations on credit
card coding uh for transactions and one
of the things that we've watched
recently uh that a lot that has alarmed
a lot of our treasurers uh is that uh
you know to code when someone makes a
purchase that's related to a gun or
ammunition
um and so we've seen we've seen that
that's a model right for potentially
being able to track uh someone's
expenditures in that area now we work
closely with some of the largest credit
card companies in the world to help make
sure that that that kind of tracking
doesn't happen and we have great
relationships with them and open lines
of communication where we can be honest
with one another when you know something
is happening like that but uh we're
we're not at that place yet where we've
got a whole lot to say about the digital
currency yeah yeah well it's a real
conundrum because
well because the digital currencies are
definitely coming you know and this is
one of the things that makes me
interested in Bitcoin because Bitcoin is
a digital currency and it literally is
decentralized that's actually true and
so you know if I had to choose between
Bitcoin as a digital currency or any
state-issued digital currency I'd take
Bitcoin hands down instantly because at
least it's distributed and that takes
control over currency and it's
monitoring out of the hands of you know
do-gooder state in or corporate
institutions for that matter because I
think at a certain level of gigantism
you know corporations are just as just
as it's reasonable to distrust them just
as much as you distrust overreach in
government and so you know that's one
place where
I think the
the genuine left has it right which is
that once corporations reached the point
where they can start to engage in
regulatory capture which is essentially
what BlackRock is doing non-stop they
pose a threat to the Integrity of
society itself yeah my assumption is is
that we'll have you know 50 states we'll
have 50 different answers on how States
should handle that and handle digital
currency that's kind of where we're what
we're seeing you know where there's
already some exploratory committees you
know that have been formed by state
legislatures
um there's like I think there's one or
two states that are already ex receiving
digital payments for uh different state
related uh payments that people make to
the state government
um and I think there's been some issues
with some of that so I think there's a
lot government always falls you know is
always a few steps behind the private
sector in terms of advancing so we're
we're we're trying to catch up and get
get more up to date on that yeah well
it's hard to stay you know the
technological transformations so so what
are your right what are your what are
the Ambitions and goals of your
organization in the next six months to a
year and and maybe a little bit beyond
that
yeah I think we continue to to make sure
that that every American you know we the
best anecdote to Wall Street is Main
Street in America uh you know we we help
Americans understand that you know this
this absolute war on American energy has
caused higher gas and diesel prices you
know combined with the logistics issues
that we had during the covet pandemic
you know uh that is why we're
experiencing inflation that's why your
eggs cost so much more that's why gas at
the pump costs much more and your bottom
line is that your paycheck isn't going
near as far as it used to be two years
ago
um you know we're going to continue to
uh our states I I think are still are
going to continue to watch companies
like BlackRock you know in the last year
uh are eight of our states divested
almost 5 billion a little over 5 billion
dollars from BlackRock
um in a move to to you know try to find
other fund managers or banks that were
willing to take their fiduciary
responsibility seriously I think you'll
see more of that I think you'll see you
know last year five states passed
legislation uh to start to move uh
federal state funds away from from the
CSG movement uh Kentucky West Virginia
Tennessee Oklahoma Texas I think you're
going to see more of that this year
um you know we're we're also educating
you know as we talked about China a
little bit you know we're we're helping
just Americans to make sure they
understand by this website that we've
created our money our values.com to go
and understand the impact that it puts
America in the position that it puts
American compared to China when we
become so interdependent on them or
dependent on them uh and other countries
for our sources of energy uh and and
where we've got plenty here that we
could be uh you know energy independent
uh yes and doing it so and doing it more
cleanly by by any measure right
absolutely you know the free market is
is is the the fix for not only the
financials but some of the cleanest
markets in the world are run by free
market governments and so uh you know
it's a
um I think you're gonna you're gonna see
more Creative Solutions I think you're
going to see more solutions on uh on
Bank you know pushing back against banks
that want to drive a political agenda
when do they do business have you guys
know you talked about Vanguard pulling
back a little bit on the ESG front last
couple of weeks I noticed that as well
have you noticed any impact of well your
organization or the broader pushback I
know Florida has been instrumental on on
this front as well have you seen any
change in the pushing forward of the ESG
agenda as a consequence of your
concerted actions
I think so you know I think BlackRock
you know was worth 10 trillion dollars
this time last year today they're worth
eight trillion dollars uh they had to
lay off three percent of their Workforce
um they've spent more money on lobbying
than they ever have in the history of
the company they've got a multi-million
dollar ad campaign on Fox News reminding
Americans you know in a warm fuzzy way
how how invested they are in their
future
um but but it it's all a sham right it's
all uh smoke and mirrors to show that
you know they are are really trying to
save face as the truth is being exposed
about again how they're weaponizing all
these other people's money to advance
their political agenda it's like this
new dark shadow government you know
that's operating uh that isn't part of
our democratic system let's I mean
that's
face it you know these guys know they
can't get it passed into courts in
America anymore they know they can't get
it passed in Congress so this is the way
they're going to try to get new policy
Advanced and we're just not going to
step by and let them do it all to atone
falsely for their unearned privilege
pretty bloody pathetic
yeah yeah so so have you have you guys
looked into what Vivek ramaswamy has
been doing on the strive front
absolutely uh you know Vivek has
actually been a speaker at our meeting a
couple of times uh in the last year uh
he has a friend and we've talked had
numerous conversations
um and and Vivek is is the beauty of the
free market right where the free market
can correct itself when things go bad uh
he launched this company called strive
Asset Management
um a year ago you know he's got a fund
that is focused on fossil fuels called
the ticker letters or drill d-r-l-l
um he's got a fund that will not do any
business with China
um and so you know he's very much taking
uh you know an opposite approach to what
BlackRock is doing and I know that he's
getting some traction some of our I I
believe some of our states are beginning
to work with with his company great well
it's going to be very interesting
watching him operate on the presidential
campaign front because he's a real wild
card you know that this next
presidential election is going to be
something to watch assuming we last that
long given the Russia Ukraine situation
but it's very interesting to see someone
like Vivek step into the ring given what
he's done on the capitol up front
already to try to push back not to push
back against BlackRock exactly but to
provide a market-based alternative
that's that's grounded in fiduciary
responsibility very interesting move on
his part I thought extremely daring and
so it's interesting to know that he's on
your well on on the radar of your of
your uh of your organization what do you
think and there's other sorry please go
ahead I was just going to say there
there are other companies aside from
strive like uh second vote asset
managers there's other companies out
there that are springing up that are
becoming a legitimate alternative to
some of these big fund managers
um which is great to see I'll let you go
ahead yeah well I mean from the Canadian
perspective it's always heartening to
see you bloody Americans try sorting
these things out like you do I mean one
of the things that's so lovely to watch
in the US in general is your your
culture is so diverse and there's so
many different pockets of Power with
that distribution of power that checks
and balances that no matter what insane
thing is going on in part of your
country there's some sane things going
on somewhere and that seems to be a
constant source of renewal on the
American front and it is especially
heartening for a Canadian to see that
because we're so bloody captured in
Canada that it's just beyond
comprehension
I think that's why vivek's message is
really getting traction this isn't an
endorsement for Vivek I love him he's a
great guy but I uh but I will say that
when you speak about American
exceptionalism and that America is a
place that anybody can come to and that
we all have the same uh opportunity to
build something great to work hard
um you know to come from nothing to be
the the son of of immigrants uh to come
over and and build a business or build a
company that's his story
um and and I'd say that that's why uh we
fight so hard is that we want it we want
that America that has it guarantees you
know not equity for all but opportunity
for all that want it that want to work
hard and and work to to provide for
their families and do what's right yeah
well equity for all is opportunity for
none that's how you make everyone right
and she just reduce them to zero and you
know the radical left gov governments of
the 20th century were damn good at that
except they didn't reduce themselves to
zero yeah it's not even true because so
often they ended up victims like often
murdered victims of their own idiot
ideology so they all ended up equal in
the ground and you know that's that's
the story of a hundred million lives in
the 20th century so all right well
um it's very interesting having you lay
all this out if people are interested in
learning more about this and also in in
what do they need to do and to
contribute what what can people do who
are watching and listening
um that's practical that would be
helpful on the on the fiduciary
responsibility front
great question well um they can go to
our money ourvalues.com uh one they can
share there's a there's about a four and
a half minute educational primer video
on that that website that explains in
plain English what ESG investing is and
how harmful it can be there's also a six
a 60 second version of that that we're
trying to get out in digital media since
December 1st we've reached 32 million
Americans
um and and had you know several million
views on our video and that's where
we're trying to to get support financial
support to go towards that so that we
can continue to educate all Americans on
the danger of this we have some
resources that they can download so they
can take questions into their registered
advisors on their on you know Main
Street USA
um we are asking uh we're asking small
business owners and Farmers to share
their stories with us on that website on
how ESG is impacting their lives or
hurting their business
um and so there is a there's a
opportunity needed to donate on that
they can follow us on Twitter at sfof
underscore States
and they can go to our website our
primary website is sfof.com they can go
and see if their state treasurer is one
of our members and if they're not they
can call them and ask them why okay
excellent well we'll put all those URLs
and contact points in the description
for this video and so all right well
that's a good overview for everybody
who's watching and listening and you
know if you want to
ensure your financial stability on the
pension front and if you want to stay
abreast of the relevant events both
corporate government that are that are
important in the in the present day and
age then you need to know a fair bit
about esgs because that's not a trivial
issue here as as we pointed out here
BlackRock and and State Street in
Vanguard own
something approximating 20 percent of
the biggest 500 companies in the U.S and
that gives them tremendous leverage it's
very necessary for people to be aware of
this and to understand that these
organizations which are Duty bound to
operate in their financial interest are
no longer doing that and that's explicit
it's an explicit part of the matter in
which they govern themselves and that
you know maybe they should be doing a
bit of a check on the governance front
you might say and of all the
organizations that I've seen that are
doing what they can to uh bring people's
attention to this problem and to do
something about it your organization is
certainly in the top one or two and so
um you know that's been very interesting
to me to watch that unfold and I'd
certainly like to wish you well in your
in your continuing Endeavors we can stay
in touch and I'll do what I can to help
I'd like that public attention to what
you're doing all right so for everyone
watching and listening we're going to
switch over to the Daily wire plus
platform for half an hour that's pretty
much standard practice with regards to
my video
um
uh we're going to continue our
conversation a little bit more on the
personal front because I'm curious about
the development of your career and and
your political and philosophical
interests and so we'll delve into that
in more detail more autobiographical
detail on The Daily wire plus platform
thank you all for watching and listening
please spread this around as much as you
are inclined to
um and uh
well thank you to the film crew here in
Calgary Alberta that's a pretty good
place to be doing that right home of the
of the fossil fuel industry in Canada
that's for sure which has been
devastated by Our Idiot prime minister
and who's planning to do a lot worse in
the future and so uh it's a good place
to be doing this interview and and uh
thanks again for for your time and for
your for your uh for the information
you've provided to everyone and we'll
definitely stay in touch in the future
I'd like that thank you so much Dr
Peterson for having me today you bet you
bet
hello everyone I would encourage you to
continue listening to my conversation
with my guest on dailywireplus.com